bonsoir nous sommes le 12 novembre
bienvenue pour une nouvelle édition de
votre journal d'information locale
l'essentiel de l'actualité du jour et il
sort aujourd'hui question de la colère
des médecins tous les syndicats de
médecins libéraux appellent à fermer les
cabinets demain 13 novembre pour
protester contre le projet de loi de
marisol touraine
le texte sera examiné en deuxième
lecture à l'assemblée nationale en début
de semaine prochaine le 12 novembre 2014
voici tout juste un an le robot fils a
été transportée par la sonde européenne
rosetta se posait sur la comète souris
une réussite à laquelle l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
s'associent nous revenons sur cet
événement historique
écrivain journaliste dessinateur exilé
en france ce dimanche à voisins le
bretonneux un après-midi de témoignages
de lecture et de musique est annoncée
nous en parlerons avec nos invités
jacques fournier directeur d itinéraire
poétique de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et également
au plateau et diane hakizimana la
journaliste burundaise exilé dans
l'actualité est également la journée de
grève des agents de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines prévue demain
vendredi l'intersyndicale cgt cfdt en
est à l'origine mot d'ordre s'opposer à
la remise en cause de leur temps de
travail
le président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin entend aligner est la durée de
travail des fonctionnaires sur la durée
légale cela va se traduire notamment par
la suppression de 13 jours de congés par
an pascal bories responsable cfdt à
saint quentin en yvelines à la
communauté d'agglomération est en ligne
avec nos bons soir pascale bories mardi
cette semaine en tout début de semaine
une réunion a été organisée entre les
syndicats les représentants du personnel
et également les élus de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
comment se sont déroulées ces
discussions on imagine que vous n'avez
pas trouvé d'accord puisque le préavis
de grève pour demain a été maintenue
donc le préavis pour le mal vient
rappeler il pas trouvé d'accord sur le
ton du travail donc nous devons faire
une contre-proposition le seul président
sur une base 2005 en plein coeur le seul
président lui est restée sur le multi
facteurs à colayrac
il ne serait pas nous n'irons pas au
delà des mots
vous étiez déjà mobilisé d'ailleurs on
en voit les images à l'antenne vous avez
déjà organisé une mobilisation lors
d'une précédente réunion du conseil
communautaire avec les élus aujourd'hui
on vous sent encore plus remontés vous
semblez assez déterminé a de la gueule
mais il ya un mais complètement total je
suis avions roman nous serons nombreux
mobilisés depuis jamais nous ne trouvons
pas d'accord nous qui sommes prêts à
faire une ovation apprécier les actions
sur 50 ha à voir au-delà donc la grève
pourrait être reconduite au delà de
vendredi
concrètement ça veut dire qu'aucun
service public ne se rassure et des
médiathèques seront fermés pour les
usagers les saint quentinois qui nous
écrase publication de drevant
mobilisation des agents et vous nous
l'avez dit mobilisation qui va se
poursuivre demain manifestation vous
allez vous vous regrouper au siège de la
communauté d'agglomération sur trappe
c'est ça à 9h30 sur le parcours de la
communauté d'agglomération nous en
remettrons pour rencontre aux vaillants
d'autre que le touquet les discussions
qu'il a eues avec avec le président et
de fuite à vélo
mais aujourd'hui justement vous êtes
encore prêt à discuter ou vous restez
sur vos positions et il n'y aura plus
aucun accord possible aucune négociation
possible
quel est votre demande aujourd'hui quel
est votre de l'autre côté la négociation
a souffert très bien nous ferons le
point la suite de ce dossier dans nos
prochaines éditions du journal merci
pascal bories responsable cgt à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous l'avez
entendu demain journée de grève pour les
agents de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines une autre colère qui
va se faire entendre aussi demain c'est
celle des médecins une journée santé
morte et en vue tous les syndicats de
médecins libéraux appellent à fermer les
cabinets pour protester contre le projet
de loi de marisol touraine une
mobilisation contre l'obligation du
tiers payant le reportage de fanny
bourdon
cela fait un an et demi qu'ils
manifestent demain vendredi 13 les
médecins libéraux vont frapper un grand
coup contre la loi santé de marisol
touraine
près de 90 % d'entre eux devraient
fermer leurs cabinets ils ont nommé leur
mouvement
le black friday là on en a un petit peu
assez on était des gentils médecin on
était des gens qui professions libérales
et là demain on va faire vraiment une
manifestation nationale qui va un peu
paralysé le pays
on en est réduit à ça parce que personne
ne nous écoute au niveau du gouvernement
dans leur ligne de mire la
généralisation du tiers payant à tous
les assurés selon les syndicats de
médecins cette mesure ajouterez de
nouvelles tracasseries administratives
et risque de se traduire par de nombreux
impayés les impayés c'est pas con
l'écran c'est qu'on sait que les
pharmaciens qui sont entières payant
depuis des années ont une marge de 10%
d'honoraires non payées soit parce que
les informations de la carte vitale sont
périmés soit parce que la sicaudais
sociale estime que cette prescription ne
doit pas être fait mais c'est tout un
lot qui est bloqué le lot bloqué pendant
un pharmacien face monte à des milliers
d'euros et éventuellement une majorité
de médecins mais aussi dentistes
kinésithérapeutes infirmiers et
orthophoniste participeront à ce
mouvement qui pourrait durer tout le
week-end
lundi ils manifesteront devant
l'assemblée nationale où la loi sera
abordé en seconde lecture et demain
vendredi les médecins préparent une
opération escargot et le partiront de la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie dû
val d'oise en direction de l' agence
régionale de santé d'île de france
installé sur paris retour à présent sur
les commémorations du 11 novembre de
l'armistice de la grande guerre de 14-18
pour ce 97e anniversaire la commune d'el
en cours a rajouté un nom à son monument
aux morts marcel durand morts pour la
france à l'âge de 24 ans il ne figurait
pas sur la stèle jusqu'à présent le
sujet est signée william l voilà
l'original
donc on est parti à partir de ça donc du
livre d'or de la commune d'el en cours
où on voit bien apparaître durant marcel
gustave donc sa date de naissance son
régiment et sa date de décès marcel
durand et un de ces héros oubliés par
l'histoire pourtant morts pour la france
durant la grande guerre son nom n'a
jamais figuré sur le monument aux morts
de la commune d'el en cours une erreur
corrigée presque cent ans plus tard par
doris bus et membre de l'association
racines
j'ai présenté à nos adhérents les livres
d'or des communes de france où sont
répertoriés tous les soldats qui sont
morts pendant le conflit
donc c'est ainsi que nous avons retrouvé
un certain durant qui est inscrit sur le
livre d'or de la commune d'el en cours
et qui n'apparaît pas sur le monument
aux morts les livres dornier ont été
instaurées qu'en 1929 alors que les
monuments aux morts ont été érigés dès
1920 un problème donc assez fréquent
chaque année en france sont plusieurs
poli qui ressorte de l'oubli je pense
que c'est important de pouvoir les
honorer chacun on en avait 10 avant on
en a onze maintenant peut-être notre pas
d'autres on ne sait pas puisque on va
continuer à creuser
c'est un moment solennel dommages et de
gratitude à l'égard de cet homme qui sur
le champ de bataille avait don de sa vie
à la france
nous nous inclinons devant la mémoire du
soldat marcel durand c'est ce mercredi
11 novembre 2015 que le nom de marcel
durand vient rejoindre celui des 10
autres pollue d'elancourt morts pour la
patrie
arrivé en 1911 dans la commune marcel
durand était âgé de seulement 20 ans
lorsque la guerre a commencé
n'ayant pas de descendants ce sont plus
d'une centaine d'elancourt toi qui
étaient présents qui lui ont rendu
hommage ainsi qu'à ses frères d'armes
chaque personne est un destin individuel
mais fait partie d'un ensemble
et rajouter un nom aujourd'hui de
quelqu'un qui ne l'avait pas été
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
essentiel on lui doit notre notre vie
notre liberté
on lui doit beaucoup une journée placée
sous le signe du rassemblement peu
importe la génération une seule chose
compte aujourd'hui le souvenir après des
lectures de lettres de poilus discours
et dépôt de gerbes tous ont rejoint la
ferme du mousseau pour assister au
vernissage d'un événement sur la grande
guerre une exposition dans laquelle
marcel durand prend une place qui lui
était dû depuis quatre ans 17 ans
et puis mardi se tenait la journée
défense et citoyenneté à la maison des
sports de plaisir organisé par le
service national cette journée est
obligatoire pour tous les jeunes de 16 à
18 ans une cinquantaine de jeunes
plaisir roi plaisir oise convoqué pour
cette journée accompagnée d'une
exposition consacrée à la france libre
et le témoignage de jean baptiste
grassin c'est un des derniers
combattants de la france libre l'homme
de 94 ans a tenu à transmettre son
expérience aux adolescents écouté mon
objectif c'est de tâcher de faire
comprendre l'importance qu'il ya de
servir le servir le pays dans lequel on
est né et tâcher de leur faire savoir
rappeler ce qu'est la parole de
quelqu'un pour ne donne pas comme ça ou
bien on ne la donne pas et une fois
qu'on l'a donnée on la respecte
je reçois à présent en plateau jacques
fournier directeur d itinéraire poétique
cette adresse est une des missions
poésie de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin bonsoir cela sera
également à diane hakizimana bienvenue
sur notre plateau vous êtes journalistes
du bondy vous avez quitté votre pays en
on va y venir on va écouter votre
témoignage dans un instant jacques
fournier le 15 novembre ce sera la
journée des écrivains persécutés
à cette occasion à la salle de la torah
voisins-le-bretonneux après-midi
témoignages lecture musique à partir de
15 heures donc ils participer l'objectif
c'est de montrer que la liberté
d'expression dans le monde va mal
aujourd'hui en fait oui va très mal et
va plus en plus mal quand on voit ce qui
se passe à travers le monde
oui la ccl nôtre c'est notre mission
dans ce service aux habitants de la
poésie que nous que nous animons avec
mon équipe c'est à dire montrer que
cette parole qui n'est pas seulement
celle des poètes dans cette occasion
dans cette semaine là que nous
organisons depuis cinq ans que la
journaliste elle est journaliste on a
reçu 1 va recevoir un dessinateur de
presse iraniens un dramaturge etc voilà
cette parole multiples elle doit être
entendue et on sait qu'elle est bridée
dans de nombreux pays
une grande majorité de pays d'ailleurs
sur sur terre et c'est ça qui
complètement dramatique et ça va pas en
s'arrangeant
et parce que c'est pas la première fois
que cette organisation c'est la saison
voilà c'est quand même mon associé au 15
novembre qui est la journée
internationale de l'écrivain en prison
or c'est un événement qui existe depuis
plus de 30 ans dont on ne parle que très
très peu en france
au pays des droits de l'homme c'est
quand même assez surprenant et vous qui
organisez cet évènement sur saint
quentin depuis cinq ans vous nous dites
la situation globalement ben moi je m'en
rends compte avec les écrivains
voyageurs l'an dernier on avait reçu des
écrivains syriens c'est vrai que bon la
syrie est une dictature depuis très
longtemps mais ça va pas en s'arrangeant
et on sait très bien il suffit de
regarder la qualité
le burundi a connu des périodes beaucoup
plus calme il ya dix ans j'aurais pas
invités ne peut être beaucoup de ou de
journalistes burundais
voilà il ya des choses qui qui bouge un
petit peu partout on peut on peut
inviter j'aurais pu inviter aussi des
dessinateurs de presse français quand on
voit les pressions auxquelles ils sont
soumis 11 x et c'est à nos portes et
donc il faut qu'on fasse très attention
et c'est un mot qui a beaucoup utilisé
maxime ndb cas le poète du congo
brazzaville nous avons invité cette
année qui parle de vigilance et c'est à
dire qu'on incite les jeunes c'est pas
du tout le but n'est pas d'en faire trop
non plus de dire pleurer margot dans la
chaumière mais de bien montrer qu'il
faut être attentif à ce qui se passe et
ce qu'on a conquis ce que nos anciens
ont conquis on en parlait avec la guerre
14-18 et les guerre 39 45
cette liberté elle est fragile et donc
il faut la préserver est non seulement
la préserver il faut l'entretenir et 15
novembre à 15 heures à la salle de la
torah voisins bretons ne devienne vous
serai présente journaliste 2014 vous
quittez le burundi après avoir dénoncé
les actes antidémocratiques du président
et aujourd'hui vous dites que la
situation est critique
membre de la société civile aux
journalistes beaucoup ont choisi le
chemin de l'exil
si j'ai fait et la mort oui c'est ça on
a un régime du président justement le
président que veut garder son mandat qui
est anti constitutionnelle qui a été
donné c'est paquette ont dénoncé par les
activistes de la société civile des
journalistes et du coup nous les aidons
dans la mort
la liberté
même lorsque vous avez avant de quitter
votre pays vous avez reçu des pressions
des appels des menaces peut-être même
des menaces de mort par j'ai fait des
reportages sur les jeunes qui était
utilisé par le pouvoir pour s'étaient
armés entraînés militairement et pour
les intimider d'autres gens dont de
l'opposition voilà des couteaux des
coups de fil vous dire que gare à vous
voilà on entendu jacques fournier dire
tout à l'heure que la situation à
travers le monde et puis pour le burundi
aussi s'aggraver et c'est alarmant
puisque l'on pourrait imaginer que au
fur et à mesure des années quand même il
ya une sensibilisation de la communauté
internationale c'est pas le cas du tout
comment vous le ressentez il n'y a pas
de les pouvoirs publics les différents
pays ne comprennent pas l'enjeu le
problème vous savez le burundi s'est
peut-être que c'est un petit pays qui
est peu connu mais aussi à ce problème
d'eau des hommes politiques certains
opposants politiques qui ont fait
tellement de ma boutique ils veulent à
tout prix garder le pouvoir pour ne pas
être rejugé après parce que ça quand ils
perdent le pouvoir ils ne sont plus les
mêmes dans du coup ils sont prêts à
n'importe quoi pour garder son pouvoir
aujourd'hui vous êtes exilé en france
comment vous poursuivez le combat
justement est ce que vous arrivez à
poursuivre ce combat
oui par l'écriture il fait des articles
sur le burundi et je dénonce tout ce qui
se passe en matière des droits de
l'homme les versions des droits de
l'homme et des assassinats politiques
voient ici c'est à garder contact avec
des gens sur place aussi encore will à
internet et à internet et
et la maison où je suis la maison des
journalistes et justement il ya un blog
où je continue à produire des articles
et vous rencontrer aussi les jeunes
puisqu'ils des rencontres ont été
organisées çà fait partie des
différentes animations proposées
vous avez déjà rencontré des élèves
justement vous avez pu échanger avec les
plus jeunes
oui les collégiens les lycéens et
c'était intéressant parce que il
peut-être qu'ils entendent ce à la radio
ils n'ont pas eu des témoignages là d'un
direct qui qui dit ce qu'il se passe
dans d'autres pays que la france
q c'est différent et changera ce rendez
vous de dimanche il y aura d'autres
journalistes des écrivains des poètes
qui seront présents aux lions peuvent
faire un point sur la journée de
dimanche oui alors dimanche sera donc à
15 heures à la salle de la tour à vos
âmes bretonneux et je remercie la ville
de voisins de nous héberger nous
accueillir
il y aura donc diane hakizimana donc
journalistes du burundi à la mohammad
qui est poète et cinéaste syrienne il y
aura un maximum dbk poète dramaturge
romancier du congo brazzaville et mana
neyestani jeunes dessinateurs
caricaturistes iranien qui que nous
avons qui est venu avec nous cet après
midi rencontrer des lycéens au lycée
villa roi voilà oui toute la journée
toute la semaine on a rencontré comme ça
ça se fera jusqu'à demain soir vendredi
plus de 500 collégiens et lycéens et ça
c'est essentiel faut savoir aussi qu'il
ya autre chose qui est organisée par la
maison de la poésie en parallèle on
prête une exposition de d'écrivains
persécutés du 20e et du 21e siècle et la
compagnie compte en bande lira quelques
textes de ces écrivains du monde samedi
à 16 heures à la médiathèque 17 mar et
c'est un moment aussi important pour
nous de faire entendre cette parole
d'écrivains de lorca desnos vaclav havel
ou zen alexievitch il vient de recevoir
le prix nobel de littérature
la faire entendre cette parole de
d'écrivains libre qui osent défier le
pouvoir absolu qu'il soit politique
religieux et idéologique pour tout
simplement dire son nom à cette cette
abomination qui est la dictature vous
sentait investi d'une mission justement
aujourd'hui encore plus maintenant que
vous êtes à l'exil et changer les choses
et avec du hockey c'est justement
j'arrive à avoir donc on ne peut plus on
a été longtemps pris mais hélas
ah ça me donne envie de continuer encore
continuer ce combat pour terminer juste
peut-être jacques fourni un dernier mot
sur l'exposition qui est proposé en ce
moment et médiathèque jacques brel
jusqu'au 21 novembre
au revoir quelques images exposition sur
lesquels on peut découvrir des textes
oui alors j'ai proposé à la ville de
voisins d'accueillir dans l'exposition
consacrée à la guerre 14-18 des haïku
des textes qui ont été rassemblées par
dominique chipeau publié chez bruno
doucey dans une anthologie qui s'appelle
en pleine figure
qui est donc ce qui rassemble ses textes
écrits par des combattants de la guerre
14-18 des haïkus c'est à dire cette
forme très courte on était au début du
xxème siècle dans la mode un peu
japonisante est donc cette forme
d'écriture était arrivé en france peu de
temps avant et on a retrouvé énormément
de textes et beaucoup ont été publiés
dans des revues pendant la guerre mais
aussi après la guerre et donc on a géré
produits sur des ardoises de terre cuite
c'est à dire cette terre qui était
utilisé dans le nord de la france et
qu'utilisaient les terrassiers pour pour
renforcer les tranchées j'ai reproduit
une quinzaine de ces textes courts qui
évoque différents aspects de ce que ses
hommes ont pu vivre au front dans la
boue dans l'horreur et dans
l'abomination voilà ils ces textes sont
éparpillés dans l'exposition
il faut faire l'effort d'aller lire
elles sont souvent posées au sol je
trouve ça très intéressant parce que
c'était là que ça se passait journée
dédiée aux écrivains persécutés écrivain
journaliste et dessinateur à travers le
monde ce sera le 15 novembre et à deux
rendez vous samedi déjà sur l encours et
puis le dimanche sur voisins le
bretonneux merci d'être venu témoigner
merci de nous présenter l'opération et
nous allons reconquérir nous allons
conclure terminé pardon cette séquence
avec justement un reportage réalisé dans
l'un des établissements où vous êtes
intervenu c'était au collège les sols
dont nous avons parlé il ya quelques
instants
rencontre entre les jeunes et puis ses
auteurs le compte rendu de sephora
namani dans la salle une trentaine
d'élèves du collège les soldes
guyancourt étaient présents andy matin
pour partager le témoignage d'écrivains
persécutés dans leur pays des
témoignages pour sensibiliser les jeunes
à la valeur de la liberté
on va bien passer la main
les reins sont faites j'ai vécu dans un
pays où la tolérance est
et notamment vraiment difficile après un
deuil parce que des gens cherchent à
toujours y aille certaines divisions
la liberté ce quelque chose d'important
que
il faut pas la brader et qu'il faut il
tenir des piles résister même quand on
est ici tout semble être bien gagner
mais il faut de la vigilance
cette rencontre avait lieu dans le cadre
de la semaine des écrivains persécutés
qui se déroule du 9 au 15 novembre
le but faire prendre conscience aux
jeunes qu'on peut être emprisonné encore
aujourd'hui dans certains pays pour un
positionnement politique ou une
expression de liberté
nous avons décidé nous en nous associant
avec le pays en club une association
centenaire qui défend les écrivains qui
sont des écrivains qui défendent les
écrivains amnesty international ai cette
année la maison des journalistes à paris
qui accueille des journalistes réfugiés
nous avons initié cette semaine qui
permet à des écrivains qui ont connu qui
connaissent encore là persécutions dans
leur pays principalement pour fait
d'écriture de rencontrer des collégiens
et des lycéens ou des étudiants organisé
depuis cinq ans par les itinéraires
poétique cette semaine propose
différentes rencontres avec les
scolaires
elle se prolongera jusqu'au 15 novembre
journée internationale des écrivains en
prison qui existe depuis 30 ans un tout
autre sujet à présent il ya un an nous
vous en avons d'ailleurs parlé dans ce
journal l'europe réussissait un exploit
historique l'atterrissage de fil à et le
12 novembre 2014 le robot est délivrée
par l'orbiteur rosetta s'est posé sur la
comète
chori après un très long voyage à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire nous
allons faire le point sur cette aventure
avec mélanie ok bon sens mélanie ça
alors on a non il ya plusieurs éléments
qui ont été rapportés et notamment la
grande porosité de la comète avec 80%
djouhri c'est donc une éponge ou une
pierre ponce
c'était une grande surprise il ya aussi
le fait que la comète est composée de
deux blocs posés l'un sur l'autre c'est
une découverte qui pourrait faire
avancer les connaissances sur l'histoire
de notre système solaire
celui-là héros filer villa et rosetta ça
sent mis au travail dès l'atterrissage
du robot écoutez anny chantal levasseur
regourd lé chercheur émérite et grande
spécialiste des comètes
le fait de pouvoir vraiment constaté peu
il est vous
et que par exemple les noyau cométaire
sont très peu denses
il est vrai qu'ils ont dû se former en
douceur aux confins du système solaire
il est vrai que les poussières
cométaires sont extrêmement peu denses
et riches en composés carbonés
il est vrai que tout cela pue peut-être
contribué à apporter non pas de la ville
mais des molécules nécessaires à
l'apparition de la vie sur terre
tout ça c'est absolument bouleversant
autre grande découverte celle faite le
28 octobre annoncée par l'agencé
européenne spatiale il y aurait aussi de
l'oxygène sûr tu souris ce qui a été
découvert donc c'est de l'hydrogène
moléculaire aux deux on appelle au lycée
le dioxygène et tous les modèles de
formation des nuages moléculaires danse
imaginez qu'il était impossible qu'il y
ait de l'hydrogène moléculaire
maintenant on n'a pas le choix il est là
et donc on se rend compte justement que
les modèles de la température de ces
nuages moléculaires et bien n'était pas
aussi précis que ce que nous savons
aujourd'hui de nombreuses découvertes
donc depuis un an et pourtant filets
lors de son atterrissage a fait peur aux
chercheurs ça a été laborieux
c'était l'avant il a fait sept heures de
descente le robot pendant plusieurs
heures il a rebondi
donc il a fallu les scientifiques ont
attendu de savoir où ils étaient et ses
robes ont été une surprise parce que les
équipes penser que fila et
s'enfonceraient sur la surface de la
comète et ce moment finalement a
énormément marqué les chercheurs je vous
propose d'écouter à nouveau a dit
chantal levasseur regourd on le
reconnaîtra toujours ce qui était le
plus bouleversant c'était de regarder
par exemple la proche de fil à et sur le
noyau et serbe ont su
ccif et je pourrais dire qu'il ya eu
presque un roman policier pour arriver à
comprendre comment par plusieurs
d'expérience quelles ont été ses rebonds
successifs quelle est sa position finale
sa position finale wilfried elle a été
compliqué à trouver parce que finalement
avec ses nombreux rebonds fila et
atterri dans un lieu très peu ensoleillé
il est couché sur le côté
il tient sur deux pieds au lieu de trois
donc cet atterrissage compliqué a
notamment modifié la mission le robot a
finalement travailler seulement trois
jours en novembre 2014
il s'étend dans les fautes de batterie
il a réussi à se réveiller en avril
dernier avant de se rendormir
et malheureusement depuis la mi juillet
rosetta n'a plus du tout aucun contact
avec lui on savait que la première
partie de la mission dure et une
soixantaine d'heures ce qui a été le cas
on espérait que l'ensoleillement
permettrait à afida et de recharger ses
batteries et de pouvoir poursuivre ses
opérations plus longtemps plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois
malheureusement fila y étant tombés dans
sans doute une cavité un trou on a dû
on a dû s'en tenir à ces trois jours
d'opérations peut-être trois jours
d'opérations pour une longue mission
même si quelques difficultés on l'a vu
puisqu'il y avait plus de soleil pour
alimenter la batterie de rosetta
le projet remonte à 93 1993 au siècle
dernier date à laquelle il a été
approuvé par le comité de programme
scientifique delehaye ça je l'avais dit
wilfried c'est à prouver en 93 il a été
lancé le 2 mars 2004 et l'atterrissage
donc le 12 novembre 2014
j'ai tout latmos l'an dernier pour
filmer l'atterrissage et je peux vous
dire qu'il régnait dans la salle nous
traitions là sur la notion là je n'étais
pas sur la comète vous avoue que ça a
été une belle aventure précis et
notamment par rapport à cette belle
émotion je vous propose de réécouter la
réaction de philippe qui est utile et
directeur du latmos le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales à guyancourt
on pense des gens qui ont travaillé très
très longtemps et qui la voit le fruit
ceux réalisés lors de leurs efforts et
puis et puis donc voilà mis en lumière
le travail des gens sur cette mission
qui est qui est emblématique
en tout onze expérience sur la sonde
rosetta une dizaine sur filet vous le
disais tout à l'heure c'est une mission
européenne à laquelle ont participé des
chercheurs français mais aussi des saint
quentinois et c'est du côté du latmos
qu'il faut se tourner le laboratoire est
basée à saint quentin
il a participé à l'élaboration de cette
des 20 instruments présents à bord de
l'orbiteur et du robot et notamment
concert à radar concert lui travaille en
transmission ce qui est très atypique on
aimait d'un côté on reçoit de l'autre et
entre deux il ya le noyau de la comète
donc là le temps de propagation à
travers la comme elle nous donne une
idée de la vitesse de propagation d'un
noyau et donc de sa porosité par exemple
de ce qu'on appelle la permissivité
qu'un mélange de porosité de composition
et de température alors les équipes
wilfrid attendent pour moment de
recueillir les données collectées par
fila et lors du périhélie c'est à dire
quand la comète était au plus près du
soleil et d'ici quelques mois l'orbiteur
devrait rejoindre son atterrisseur le
périhélie découvre des nouveaux gros
écart va se rapprocher de toutes façons
de la comète pour observer les
modifications après son passage près du
soleil et la fin préprogrammés de la
mission c'est que l'orbiteur va se
rapprocher de plus en plus du noyau et
éventuellement même si c'est possible
atterrir sur le noyau pour faire des
observations très proche d'eux
du noyau qu'en outre impossible
l'aterrissage d'euros étalé les
scientifiques espèrent avant tout que
l'orbiteur et le robot parviendront un
repos à reprendre contact dans les
semaines à venir
wilfrid tour il n'a pas fini de révéler
tous ses secrets je reviendrai pour le
prochain anniversaire pour les deux ans
de la mission bon anniversaire donc à
rosetta et à cette mission qui s'était
posé vous l'avez suivi
on imagine avec beaucoup d'intérêt comme
tous ces phénomènes comme la lune rouge
par exemple ou ce genre de choses que
mélanie suis toujours avec beaucoup
d'attention merci c'est la fin de cette
édition du jeudi je vous retrouve demain
vendredi pour le journal de la semaine
l'essentiel depuis lundi et puis
l'essentiel du jour bien sûr
rendez vous demain excellente soirée sur
notre antenne